bonjour pierre rehov merci de répondre à
nos questions en direct sur arte france
ces nouvelles consignes de vaccination
sont appliquées depuis hier en israël
pourquoi le gouvernement at il pris la
décision de vacciner l'ensemble de la
population adulte dès maintenant
pourquoi une telle accélération dans la
campagne
bonjour ils vont vite être le vrai goût
écoutez c'est tout simple la population
risque dire la population depuis de 60
ans a déjà été vaccinées à peu près à
hauteur de ne pas dire de bêtises de 88%
c'est à dire qu'on a arrêté un taux de
vaccination pratiquement la totalité de
la population risque donc il faut
maintenant bay tant attendu qu'il y
avait quand même reçu quantité très
importante de vaccins de pfizer et
modern art d'ailleurs j'en profite parce
que je viens de voir le reportage
précédent pour préciser que l'on n'en
parle pas beaucoup mais israël vient
d'offrir 10 mille doses de vaccin à
l'autorité palestinienne
bon évidemment l'autorité palestinienne
ne parlera pas posé de questions
politiques que vous pouvez imaginer
et comment se déroule la campagne de
vaccination en israël est ce que le pays
fait face à des retards de livraison
comme certains pays l'union européenne
par exemple mais on sait quand même que
l'état hébreu a payé au prix fort un les
vaccins pour être libre et quand même
évidemment parce que c'était un calcul
qui est extrêmement intelligent payer
les vaccins à 40% de plus que le prix
normal pour les avoir en priorité
rapport à la population c'est déjà une
avancée spectaculaire
d'autre part si longtemps strictement
économique chaque journée 2-2 de laudun
de confinement chaque journée de non
reprise économique coûte beaucoup plus
cher que l'argent qu'elle peut dépenser
pour avoir ces vaccins priorité donc aux
jeunes d'aujourd'hui israël a
suffisamment de vaccins a déjà comme
vous voulez des deux de le dire vacciner
30 % de cette population jeu mais a
suffisamment de vaccins constante ou à
venir pour que à peu près que l'on soit
vacciné avant la dent lâche 1 l'as en
avril je crois vous avez parlé de lock
down ce qui veut dire confinement en
anglais ce sont les derniers jours un
confinement en israël comment le
gouvernement peut partir prépare-t-il à
la levée des restrictions qui semble
imminente alors poursuivie jusqu'à
dimanche alors qu'ils devaient
s'interrompt dont on a encore trois
journées de plus de confinement et il
s'agit
un déconfinement par par phases c'est à
dire que comme on l'a déjà vécu l'année
dernière
dans un premier temps les restaurants
sans autant réouvrir vont pouvoir à
nouveau livré sur place alors que
jusqu'à présent il fallait commander
pour le recevoir
recevoir des six nations et puis il ya
tout un système qui s'est mis en place
pour que certaines écoles ouvrent pas
d'autres certains quartiers soient
évidemment plus plus tolérer quelques
d'autres parce qu'il faut savoir que
quand on parle de pourcentage de
population on oublie que certaines zones
sont beaucoup plus touchés que d'autres
les quartiers luttent pas religieux sont
beaucoup plus touchés que les plus hauts
pics à la vive par exemple les villages
arabes sont beaucoup plus touchées
également que tel et ville tout
simplement parce que il ya beaucoup
moins de respect de la loi dans ces
zones là que dans 2 que là où je vis
c'est à dire à tes la ville vous avez eu
l'autre jour le l'enterrement la
cérémonie funèbre d'un rabbin de très
haut niveau de faire respecter par les
ultra orthodoxes
cent mille personnes se sont présentées
se sont rendus à ses funérailles
est-ce qu'ils portaient des masques des
si le savoir quand vous avez cent mille
personnes qui sont réunis donc
globalement des endroits comme tel avis
sont très peu touchés on peut voir
d'ailleurs que dans les rues le
confinement n'est pas extrêmement
respectée parce que les gens respectent
beaucoup d'autres choses ils portent des
masques et à sa distance les uns des
autres
vous avez vous avez une vous avez un
moment s'appelle une prise de
température à l'entrée dvd des
supermarchés et c'est donc avec quelques
mesures extrêmement simple israël arrive
quand même à globalement aura
globalement malheureusement pas
complètement puisque je crois qu'on a eu
parce que justement vous dites que le
confinement est prolongé donc jusqu'à
dimanche
et en même temps c'est peut-être parce
qu'à une recrudescence des cas constatés
chez la population est ce que le pays
est confronté au nouveau variant du
duco vide 19 oui on a déjà eu
malheureusement n'y a pas que y'a pas
que varié en viennent à plusieurs je
crois qu'il ya plus de 4000 var et non
du virus
on ne sait pas encore si le vaccin
protège aux vêtements de toutes ses
variantes dont on est en il ya plein de
plein d'inconnues mais il ya quand même
une chose qui est finalement simple à
comprendre et à connaître c'est que le
vaccin protège à peu près une semaine à
deux semaines après avoir la deuxième
dose donc on n'a pas encore de chiffres
suffisamment important sur le nombre de
gens qui a reçu la deuxième doit je
crois que enfin moi j'en fais partie
d'une deuxième 2 j'ai déjà un deuxième
tour donc mes amis en france me dit que
je suis à mon sujet m pour ma part j'ai
l'impression d'être peut-être dans un
complètement immunisé
mais aujourd'hui le problème le problème
est là c'est que on n'a pas encore de
données suffisantes pour savoir si lui
aussi la vaccination va permette très
rapidement de pouvoir sortir de la
pandémie et les chiffons comment tu
d'augmenter parce que vous savez après
un an et quelque 2,2 de confinement un
jour oui un jour non on reprend en a eu
en israël un peu quand même les mêmes
problèmes que les autres pays rue c'est
à dire une ignorance delà de la réalité
de cette pandémie de ce qui se passe
véritablement de la dangerosité de ces
quarts or c'est quand même quelque chose
de très nouveau c'est passé sur la
planète est longue les jambes à un
certain moment où au moins c'est vous
savez il suffit de pas grand chose vous
avez porté votre masse toute la journée
où vous êtes comporté en excellent
citoyens vous avez respecté toutes les
normes
et puis ben vous appuyez sur le bouton
de l'ascenseur sans y faire attention
et puis vous gratter le nez de secondes
après et ça y est malheureusement vous
êtes contaminés alors vous avez fait
tout ce qu'il fallait pendant un an
donc cette cette dangerosité le
potentiel du petit détail est à mon sens
la chose la plus dangereuse de ce pays
aujourd'hui
merci à pierre graff d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
reporter et écrivain en direct de tel
aviv